what's about the new movie book-smart it
was good yes is really hurt no you know
what I will tell you something there are
people that come on and they talk about
their movies and some of them are like
okay this movie people love it if you
don't really love it it's got this great
critical praise and you will set it up
for people who want to shove a clip but
oh okay well I'm playing that with Will
Forte we're the parents of Caitlyn
Devers character and she and beanie
Feldstein are going out that night but
they don't want to tell us where they're
going and we also think that they are
girlfriends and that we're fine with
that
yes you know but yes we're not
completely fine but we're trying right
you miss you you're under the impression
that they are girlfriend yeah and
they're not and they're not and we're
trying to be fuzzy yeah let's take over
this clip from book-smart
we just want as much time together as we
can before she leaves her Africa we made
mushroom cap and gowns yeah made special
names for all this stuff great deal of
care was taken well
chips and salsa long high school cheese
and Salah me being your dad was the
greatest honor of my life yeah
everything has a name I love my baby
girl
that's Apollo's thank you know what we
get it but we get it yes we understand
you say what you two have doing what
they have is very very special yeah it
really is it is you know they say you
never forget your first friend special
friend normal friend I have my special
friend yeah I'm just so thankful we get
to spend the whole night together to
really show each other how much we care
about each other
that's great oh my girl alright we just
do a Korean face mask I don't need to
know all the words
[Laughter]
and that's my part in the movie
nobody does uncomfortable as well as you
I comedic Lee in Syria I mean nobody you
do this know it's hilarious hey with
hilarious